all in all it's just another gap
in the wall yes mr president it's a lot
to tackle
when you're out of spackle an exclusive
report in the washington times says
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas thank you told his department
that he may resume
border wall construction to fill in the
holes
new york has reportedly told ice
employees that although biden has
stopped any money from going to the wall
it leaves room to make decisions
on finishing quote gaps in the wall
which by the way is still building a
wall you idiot
what do you think walls do
[Laughter]
you open walls where there are walls you
put them where there are gaps
geez louise do i have to solve
everything meanwhile republican senator
john barrasso claims an administration
official
uh told him and other senators while
visiting the border
to delete the photos they took of the
migrant facilities housing children
or wait to publish them during a
republican administration
that was a joke he told maria bartoromo
lovely person
but none of them complied this is both a
humanitarian crisis
uh and a national security crisis i saw
both at the border and you may have seen
the numbers today
are the highest in history of
unaccompanied minors currently in
captivity
they are crammed in like sardines and
this is what the biden administration
is trying to hide from the american
public which is why we took video
and the biden administration tried to
stop us
one thing's for sure immigration is a
complicated sensitive subject
maybe that's why people often just see
what they want to see
right gen saki jen
i'm gonna show you some images and just
tell me what comes to mind
okay um i would say that is um
definitely not
a photo of kids in
uh cages and uh what about this one oh
that's
that's very interesting question and i
would just say um
that is not um two kids in
two cages
and this wow a
butterfly i'm sure
i mean i'm sure that some people might
see a um
dolphin i definitely do see a
butterfly um and unfortunately that's
also
all the time for questions at this time
well done
cat everybody keeps saying
this uh this problem keeps happening
every year blah blah blah
why does this this story keep existing
why does this keep happening why do you
think
do you think it's secretly there's a
large group of people who don't want
this
conflict to go away do you have a
solution
well yeah i mean my look this isn't new
for democrats right because
even obama and hillary in the past voted
for a border fence
yes and then they of course evolved on
that but of course it keeps coming back
the only people who have not won this
nurse have been libertarians
but we also want to you know remove the
welfare incentives
so that people wouldn't come here i
don't really understand how you could
want to open the border and
have a welfare state at the same time
does not make sense to me yeah but i
don't know i mean look in the past when
we were talking about this it was at
least more fun
uh because trump would say stuff like
remember what he said he wanted to make
it see-through
so you didn't get hit with a 60-pound
bag of drugs if somebody threw it over
no they did that that's why they're
saying you're like
i'm just saying designed believe me
there was much discussion
in the administration about the slats
like the slats
i think some people would see 60-pound
bag of drugs as an opportunity
you ignorant slat did you work on any of
this in the administration i did
for a little bit uh yeah it's really
it's really awesome
it's really great to see that the wall
is still open and uh
yeah it's i mean no it's frustrating i
think um
you know the biden administration is
figuring out that like actually
immigration is really hard and it's a
really
that was you watched yeah now and like
now
now they're like well i guess we you
know it's like a kind of a crisis down
there maybe we're gonna have to fill the
uh
gaps but we're not building a wall and
it's kind of like i mean the way that i
see it is sort of like welcome to the
party guys like this is you know
welcome to trying to solve the border
like maybe they'll actually uh
be forced by shame by many little
toddlers wandering through the desert
will finally force them to actually do
something about this but um
yeah i'm not holding my breath i mean i
think they're more likely to build a
monorail
than to actually fix the wall high
speeds like they're gonna do like a high
speed from tijuana
and have mexico pay for it charlie is is
this one of those
political games that just flips sides
based on administration like now it's
biden's turn to defend it and then next
time when uh
um who's going to be president after him
rhonda sanders
yeah do you think so yeah
but no no i think i was gonna say
anthony weiner but okay
he's gonna try yeah but but i do think
that uh you know i think that they
have played this game for so long and
they've used it as a cudgel
uh in in order to sort of get votes and
gin up uh support
but the problem is what they're finding
out is if you actually let the poor
the border completely collapse then you
wind up with
a really severe serious problem that
cuts across
all sort of all of their their lines
their their racial
you know gender lines everything and
everybody is appalled
by it but one of the things that i think
is so interesting about this story
is uh you saw the story where the two
yemeni
uh people on the the terror watch list
uh were caught
at the border dhs put up a press release
about the fact they caught them
and then they took the press release
down yes they did they're embarrassed
yes about catching uh suspected
terrorists at the border
what is going on here do you know why
they were embarrassed about calling them
suspected terrorists when in fact the
administration wanted them to be called
undocumented vacationers i really think
that really may be
it and one of the problems really may be
that well what if they want to uh
claim asylum in in this country and it's
like i'm sorry wait how did we get here
i don't know
i'd like to claim asylum for me and my
bomb yeah
i don't know joe joe you seem to have
all the answers but you're keeping them
to yourself and that bothers me
well well greg i thought biden was
mostly stealing bernie sanders ideas but
if he's if he's filling in the wall
maybe he's stealing from trump too yeah
maybe he can unite us yeah but the thing
this is just another one of those things
that trump
instincts were proven correct but they
can't agree with him because they hate
him so much
like he said he just was against the
wall they would support him yeah he
should come out against the wall
tomorrow
that would be really really funny